i had such a great time watching this
movie i just wanted to get up and dance
which i thought would be rude to the
people sitting behind me but
it's a lot of fun
it is i'm glad you liked it
i'm curious with such a beautiful
magical film about
the importance of family and with so
many characters and so much culture and
great music and so much going on
what makes this film special to you and
what does being a part of this mean to
you
i mean gosh it just
so many things come to mind because this
film really encompasses a lot of
what i strive for and what you know what
i've worked so hard for which is for my
family you know to keep my family
together
uh to
honor my family and all of the things
that i do and sharing my gifts with the
world you know it's everything that that
that i've done um and of course being
from colombia having my family being
from colombia it's it's incredible it's
an incredible honor to be represented uh
in this way
uh especially on a
in a disney film right i mean
that seemed almost impossible especially
when you think about the kind of
representation that a country like
colombia has received um in the past
which is mostly negative and you know
it's so
counter
active to what i've actually experienced
in colombia which is exactly what you
guys see in the film the love of family
the colors the music the food all of
those flowers um
the the connection to magic um and and
that belief um is very much embedded in
our culture and so to see it represented
in this way is a dream come true when
this character was presented to you what
was your reaction to her but also
whether or not you could embody her
oh yeah no i i um
immediately i understood why i was cast
as isabella because
um
you know i i
i am
her a little you know i
i feel like i
i watch disney movies and i watched
disney princesses and you know i sort of
like lived in that magical fantasy land
as a kid
and i sort of always wanted to be a
princess and
um
you know
anytime my mom told me that i was a
princess i i truly believed it and um
you know it was something that i really
desperately wanted to embody yet i
didn't understand
what really makes a princess which is
um
what you feel inside and your courage to
speak up for yourself um
your ability to change and to make
mistakes and to be human right not just
this like physical embodiment of a
princess and the twirls and the making
flowers and all that like my uh much
like my character
um
you know
beauty beauty isn't just what's
aesthetically beautiful and and what's
on the outside it really is should and
is um what you have inside
what was it like to see
what she would look like what her gift
would be and to hear yourself
bringing her to life
yeah it was a surreal experience you
know because it's um
to see
a character
um
from
this place that you were
you know from colombia i was so afraid
that like i wasn't ever going to be
understood you know like
as far as like when i would try to talk
about what i m what my experience was
when i would go to this magical place
you know but it was rarely portrayed
um in film and in storytelling in this
way like i couldn't really
you know put words to or a feeling to
what i saw and so
to see myself be a part of something so
monumental um
was
just an incredible feeling you know
incredible sense of
uh
accomplishment you know on on my part as
far as like you know
wishing that that something like this
could happen to me and and putting
putting myself first in the ways that
like i allowed myself to dream and
allowed myself to have this opportunity
you know it's not easy to
to
be here and to get here and to and to
get to
um tell a story like this one so i'm
incredibly grateful and
yeah feeling so blessed
everyone sees isabella as the perfect
maginot
and i love how this film also explores
the weight and pressure that comes with
having to be the one that everyone
expects to be perfect
and at the same time her perfection is
just a little bit annoying which makes
it easy to understand mirabelle's
frustration with her you
ever want to roll your eyes at her
perfection i mean were there ever times
where you're like oh my god i can't
believe she's acting like that
no because
um
you know
perfectionism is obnoxious
it is annoying and it's not good for
anybody you know so
i i yeah i had to take that sort of like
burden of an unlikable
trait but it's it's true and um
perfectionism is annoying and it's
boring and it's you know it's not good
for anybody and i'm so glad that even
though um you know she expresses herself
in this way that that is a product of
what
this notion of perfectionism does to a
person it makes them shallow it makes
them empty and
you can't really see who's really there
and that's why i really appreciate my
story arc because
you see her
break free from that and really you see
what what is the key ingredient to
breaking free from from perfection from
these ideas that society imposes in you
is love
love makes you freak break free from
that and it's the love of your family
it's a love of mirabella and isabella
and so i think it's a beautiful message
you're also a part of another very
unique kind of wacky and wild family
with doom patrol
what has it been like to
play that character and and explore
someone so unique in that way
uh gosh it's been a really great
opportunity for me to explore certainly
so many different versions of myself and
so many different emotions um you know
like isabella
she shows kind of you know mainly
a few a few emotions but mainly one
that's like hiding
whereas jane on doom patrol really can't
hide a lot of her emotions because
that's all she is
and um yeah it's been an incredible
opportunity uh to to bring a story like
that to life you know that show is so
grounded in the absurd you know in
impossibility i mean it's it's quite
magical
as well um so i i i feel very fortunate
to get to explore the theme of mental
health um through a superhero story it's
unlike anything out there so yeah i'm
feeling i'm feeling pretty cool
and what did you love about the music i
mean how exciting is it to get to to do
songs like this
yeah it's incredible i mean lin-manuel
is and is just an incredible uh
steward of of this gift and and you know
a great storyteller of our culture i
hope that
um
that we see this as
as um you know an example of
how much more there is out there and
what the possibility of of more is um
and i just hope to see uh more people
telling stories like this writing more
music because there's i mean you heard
this you heard that uh the music from
that lin created using the richness of
our culture there's so much more out
there so i i hope that this film invites
more of that
well thank you for talking about it i
love all of these characters they're
just so much fun thank you so much